what is up everybody it seems like there
has been a super major leak regarding
Avengers 4 and that is that it appears
that the title has been leaked this
seems to be very legit and in this video
I'm going to explain why but we have for
now a title for Avengers 4 and that is
Avengers endgame let's start off by just
noting that logically this makes sense
this is actually what I thought the
title would be because in Avengers
infinity war Doctor Strange says we're
in the endgame now and he says it at the
end of the movie he says it after he
gives Thanos the time stone and keep in
mind he saw the future he knows the only
way that they can win and we know that
everything went according to plan
because at the end of the movie as
Doctor Strange is beginning to
disintegrate he looks at stark and says
this was the only way so we know that it
went how it was supposed to go and that
means that the end game is whatever the
avengers do afterthe anos a snap which
is what avengers 4 is going to be all
about so logically this makes sense and
is a good title for Avengers 4 so now
let's talk about where the leak came
from the leak came from Avengers 4
cinematographer Trent oppa Locke Trent
is very legit he worked on Captain
America the Winter Soldier Captain
America Civil War and Avengers infinity
war and now Avengers apparently endgame
so how did he leaked it well Trent has a
website for all of his work of course
and on his website he lists movies that
he's worked on and up until this morning
the latest movie that he was working on
said Avengers endgame the title was
taken down and it just says Avengers for
now but we managed to get our hands on a
screenshot before it was taken down so
of course the Russo brothers have
already commented on this and they said
Avengers in game is not the title for
Avengers 4 but these are also the same
guys that told us that all of the heroes
that turn to ash and Avengers infinity
war are dead for good and we know that's
not true I mean
we have spider-man far from home coming
out there's definitely going to be a
second Black Panther movie guardians of
the galaxy three is confirmed and
confirmed to take place after the events
of Avengers four Doctor Strange 2 is
happening and let's not forget how hard
they told us for an infinity war putting
things like The Hulk and scenes in
Wakanda when the Hulk never came out so
sure they say it's not the title but
what does that even really mean there's
really no way to know it could very well
be the title whether it is or not either
way I think the Russo brothers are
probably getting a pretty good laugh at
this right now and on a final note we do
know that this will be the end for some
of the actors that are playing the roles
of some of the original Avengers so in
game Falls kind of into place with
what's happening there as well so there
you have it Avengers end game let me
know what you all think of this I
personally think that this is a super
fitting title but let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
and if you liked this video be sure to
hit that thumbs up button if you would
like to stay up-to-date on Avengers 4
hit that subscribe button with the
notifications turned on when anything
comes out I get it to you as fast as I
can thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]